he's one of the most exciting fighters
on the ufc roster he drove himself out
from fontana california it's bobby green
on this week's food truck diaries and
i'm feeding them gordo's hot chicken
sandwiches on this week's food truck
diaries let's go
from my wallet to my check i don't want
it if it's skinny but i need it if it's
dead
need a thick girl
[Music]
i need
[Music]
mr bobby green
what's going on big dog
looking fly man
that's an outfit i could not pull off
that's right i take some risks but you
look pretty dope man appreciate your
brother i try something different every
time you know a little this a little dab
yeah you'll see me in this and this
you'll see me in a suit yeah you got
some swag to you man i try to get some
swag you're one of the biggest
personalities in the ufc
and i feel like right now i've wanted
you on the show for a while i've been
following for we've talked about off
here i've been falling for a hot second
you're one of the guys i've won on the
show
and now
i guess you could say similar to
mozville at all it's like you guys are
these
journeyman's the wrong term because
journeyman's like you know i hate that i
hate it
i'm trying to think of a better word but
i would say late bloomer
late bloomer but i wouldn't say you're
late i guess late bloomer to the general
thing yeah but for the hardcores like
they've been fans of you guys for a
while so for you guys finally get your
shine
i think for the hardcore it's like oh
finally man finally you guys are getting
some recognition
that's that's the perfect word finally
you know it's like i was getting ready
she's like maybe i should sit it down
you know yeah and then i was like like
you ran a mile right and at the end of
the mile they're like you did really
great but we need you to run another one
because now it's like now it counts yep
now it's like now people are watching
before two people are watching around
that mile now you got millions of people
watching around that mile yeah but i
still stick to the same philosophy it's
still the same goals and just being you
bro that's it you know i've been the
same person back then i'm just kind of
like well now you're catching on like a
lot of people make fun of me and a lot
of people say my style wouldn't work
interesting mma you know like damn curry
would say the shoulder roll you can't do
that in a medicine that he's like
mayweather so i proved that mayweather
they said that he couldn't do the sport
well i could do it you know
where where a boxer couldn't come and do
these different no i showed that it
could actually be worked and done you
know yeah you do it your way with your
original with it which i think people
admire and that's why people follow you
um but it hasn't been easy i mean one of
the reasons i want you on the show
is
you know your your background i think
it's inspirational you know and we have
uh cleo roundtree who's another
inspirational guy coming on soon but
there's these stories inside the ufc
where
you know the ufc highlights is you know
as much as they can but to me it's like
with your story and your background it's
just so inspirational because
along the way we talk about you just
getting shine now along the way it's
been so easy for you to go down a
different path you know
it's just
your background i feel like is so
inspirational and so many people maybe
they haven't heard this story it's just
it's insane ben
says that to me he says that you should
keep repeating it you think that people
have been following the story but people
who didn't know like some people think
i'm just been rich and i've been this
guy who know i was broke poor foster
care since i was four years old you know
um didn't have a mom didn't have a dad i
was her my grandmother raised me but the
only way she got me was that they didn't
know that my dad was my dad because my
name is bobby green and his name is
something different and i'm not named as
my mom either weird crazy stuff but
basically my grandmother got me into
from foster care and she died i didn't
mean to interrupt you but your grandma
took you under her wing because your mom
was a addict is that correct yes sir yes
sir yes sir and so my dad came
got us from there um no my dad was took
into prison my my mom came and brought
us to a house one day she walked us up
there she walked away and i was like i
hadn't seen her for like four years
after that that's her every once in a
while and when she walked you to your
grandma's it was you your brother
me my brother yup me and both of my
brothers i'll show you another one
brother yeah yeah two brothers you know
um
no no i'm the middle
older brother and a younger brother
gotcha and so that's the family circuit
and then this one my younger brother got
killed correct yeah and my bigger
brother got took it away and fought from
foster care they took him into another
home
and so i kind of made it it's just been
a crazy storm brother it's been a crazy
storm and i've been holding on and
trying to stay positive you keep a smile
but at the same time [ __ ] is nuts you're
human yeah but you have this tough
exterior you know but inside has to be
tough i want to get into i know the guys
want to get to the truck so
definitely get into this i don't want to
interrupt you let me feed you some you
drove all the way from fontana yes sir
which is how far it's about an hour and
a half you know it was about it's not an
hour and 32. now you're i was known as
the guy that drove all over california
to find the best training when i was
fighting i would drive from venice beach
i know you don't know the coast like
most people do but i would drive from
venice beach to orange county five days
a week during the middle of rush hour
traffic in a prius and i would get out
of my prius and kick the prius and then
i would head back around noon i would do
condition in santa monica rest and then
i would drive in rush hour traffic rough
rough or rush hour traffic to redondo to
train with henry gracie so you're
looking at you you're looking about five
hours a day of sitting in the car you
got me being on the previous part i just
thought i'll go get it like two g's and
go buy a [ __ ] car and i just drive it
around and just butt around
but still
yeah yeah we were talking we're talking
like uh like a honda
okay it depends it depends
depends on the situation how i feel for
instance there's some situations where
like right now gas is crazy so like it's
just a four banger you know little four
cylinder right around 100 or
i'll get a trick car a trick car is like
i'm gonna buy this car and then i'm
gonna wrap it some crazy just so i'm
gonna put a lamborghini doors on it just
and i only spent two g's on it so if i
put another two
you got a four thousand dollar car you
know so when he's talking about gas is
crazy obviously
the audience knows guys crazy in
california i filled up yesterday it's
seven dollars
seven dollars well let me feed you some
free food bro it cost me 83 bucks to
fill my tank god damn it what are we
doing well this doesn't cost you
anything let me feed you yes sir let's
get it
[Music]
what's up brother what's up man gordo's
hot chicken man how's business going
brother it's good it's good yeah i dig
the hat man thank you we got heads for
both of you guys dope definitely rock
that yeah yeah okay i'm a rock and
checker what do you uh what do you
suggest here man so our most popular
sandwiches are plates there's a sandwich
combo and the gordo fries the gordo
fries is the least messiest so i would
recommend that one but anything on the
menu is good never scared a little more
turtle fries are the least messiest
the gordo burger yeah it has tater tots
mac inside the burger why are you trying
to [ __ ] your pants ah
yeah dog
first yeah i'll do the combo number one
i'll do the sandwich combo sounds good
what about you bobby i want to do the
grilled cheese combo
i'm not mad at that at all you want
pineapple coleslaw and the grilled
cheese
pineapple in the grilled cheese
pineapple coleslaw oh damn nuts as well
uh let's do it inside just in case you
never know i'm not a kosovo but i might
like it you know smart play yeah you
guys came down from oxford love it up
there man yeah it's dope do you pick the
treasure they pick the trucks how does
that work uh we all kind of do yeah we
put out a bat signal and then certain
people that's like certain contracts
like yeah we're in man and then yeah
great business with this great business
yeah
the thing about la there's so many good
food trucks so like to highlight a good
food truck that's what i'm saying yeah
that's great exposure for them also and
you'll see like you know in l.a
especially like the food trucks are like
legit food man legit we've only had
probably one bad food truck
these steamed burgers was a nightmare
with cheryl sonin oh no tim kennedy two
years at least you're honest at least
you're honest keep it real tim was dead
honest they added a lot of it out and he
goes you're steaming the burgers and guy
goes yeah and tim goes don't do that
and the guy gets that's what we do he
goes i'm telling you don't do that
[Music]
chicken
[Music]
let's take a little break from chatting
and
in our face with bobby green cause man
my friends at peloton they're pushing
you further with so much they have so
much going on the peloton bike time bike
plus they have new classes new music new
ways to keep your workouts fun and
motivating they're offering boxing now
yeah that's right do you need gloves
nope do you have to get punched in the
face nope you can do it from the comfort
of your home and get a great workout
with their phenomenal peloton
instructors they have new artist series
music selections all right
work out to the music that you love man
pop rock hip hop edm they have over 100
artists series to choose from so you can
find your favorite music and get to work
and shed them calories man visit
onepeleton.com to learn more that's
o-n-e-p-e-l-o-t-o-n.com
now let's get back to the program all
right my man let's dig in they put your
uh pineapple coleslaw on the side for
you the mac and cheese looks pretty
legit
and so you don't know but i'm a food
connoisseur like oh really i was
thinking like maybe i should have a show
where i just go i have fights but then i
go and try
and try foods and and rate them you know
and judge them so we're going to get
this to the rating i wanted to give them
a raise you're gonna give it a rating
yeah if you is there good food out in
fontana
what
what
right
brother there's good food everywhere you
just gotta search true
but what like what's the go to in
fontana oh my god it's amazing yeah i'm
telling you these foods that is amazing
i'm not a coleslaw fan but the way they
kind of put the cream in with it it's
going you know i'll definitely go with
that i know that with chicken sandwiches
you always got to mix the coleslaw with
them it's like the thing they're doing
it's pickles and
or it's coleslaw yeah that's fire
yeah good um and fontana what's the
what's the go-to
um
so if i was in fontana
they got something called miguel's sushi
you ever had one of those miguel sushi
mm-hmm that's like a mexican guy making
sushi yeah it's like a mexican hard
pasta
really it's in style what are you
talking about so it's just a little
different like the temp tempura is like
uh flavored cheetos they're doing all
that stuff too you know like uh like
normal
uh
like type sushi but
they're gonna do it i mean temperature
they still have to emperor but they just
do it a little bit different you know
it's just a little bit different not too
much different you know
it's chill i like that type of stuff i'm
into everything brother like i like
italian i'm really big enough to like
italian foods mexican foods i'm into
everything i mean i'll try out miguel's
sushi another cause you recommend it but
if i was gonna buy a place that said
miguel sushi it'd be a hard pass you
know what i'm saying i first i was kind
of like that too but sushi is my
favorite food
so i'm like
give it a try i'm good i feel like
that's what you got to do brother like
you always have to try something new
yeah that's what life's about having
something new agree so for you
you're coming off the loss to makachev
which i want to get into geez yeah i
know right but but i see i don't
yeah technically it's a loss but also
i think you gained the respect not that
you didn't have respect before but i
think you gained the respect of the fan
base
makachev's fan base like you kind of
saved that card you know what i'm saying
to take it on a late notice also
it's a big it was a risk-free and it
wasn't because i think no matter what
the outcome
you gain the respect and i don't think
you
like lose your
your spot in line you know because
you're coming off two wins you know you
had a really good year
so
contractually like you were we were
talking about your six fight deal right
so no no no no no four four yeah and so
you're so was was the end of the four
coming off these two wins so i thought
fees f
monster the first play tonight decision
fight of the night i fought out next
and i like winter knocked him out then i
fought the
uh uh nazareth
and so fight i felt like i'm on fire
right now i'm getting it rolling yeah
you already lost your fight of the night
and then i get to toss this other one i
feel like you kind of just throw a
monkey at the wrench and or is it a
monkey in your ranch or is it one of the
ranchers in one of those monkeys
a lot of monkeys but
so they called you like hey we know you
don't have a fight left on your contract
mark chapman he had one left oh and this
was that was mankind
and so jason calls me my manager he's
just like hey you wanna you wanna do the
fight i'm like
be honest i'm gonna be honest gay i'm
real i was smoking
on vacation sitting on the couch i enjoy
myself when i'm off you know when it's
work time it's work time when it's not
it's not you know and so
i'm hanging out
my girl's getting ready to have surgery
the next day
surgery like uh she was gonna have knee
surgery oh gotcha she's learning
um
yes that worked she unless she tweaked
her knees okay so it worked yeah blew
her knee out yeah so she's gonna have
surgery the next morning we're packing
the bags and the mug fight was how much
of a notice 10 days okay
i'm sitting in the couch i'm fat i'm
eating stuff like this yes yeah now i'm
190
95 pounds
you know they want to get back down to
55 in 10 days are you are you are you
nuts no no no no when they threw when
they told you
to have 10 days i'm assuming there's
some compensation
additional conversations they're like no
this is your one fight but it's 10 days
but you're kind of doing them a solid
of course of course i mean i'm not gonna
risk
my name my
legacy and all the stuff not to be
compensated so they definitely took care
of me
and and that's the end goal you know
like
i weighed it kind of out
you could just go in there and like it
was a [ __ ] show just to throw this
together not to mention
everything else that came behind i could
tell you a thousand things that happened
up into that fight that i didn't realize
that i was dealing with like ones um
media
you started immediate at 9 00 a.m well
because now you're the main event main
event happy livestream 9 00 a.m we
didn't finish to like three four o'clock
i was like
like there do you miss your training in
the morning you miss food i barely even
had a sip of water you know there's a
a video that went pretty viral max chef
is getting annoyed too about doing all
that media
it's nuts and khabib tells them goes as
coach says just lose this all goes away
all you gotta do is it's really easy
it's simple just lose and all this
all this medium publicity all goes away
all you gotta do is lose dude and this
all goes away he was like this is easy
he slaps on back he's like come on stay
focused can you see makachev
he's not you know he's new to the main
events and again it heavy lies the crown
like everybody wants to be a champ till
you gotta do champs [ __ ] man and and i
think frank mayer's talked about brock
lesnar it's
you know once you're a main event
or you're the heavyweight you know or
world champion in general you have so
much more responsibility
yeah
um so that was that was a title wave you
weren't ready all that mark and
everything i just want to challenge that
with your standing a little bit
i would say
you said don't lose if you lose it'll be
over now because guys like like nate
these lose or hey man they'll lose it
and they're still stars different though
right why for market though wow he's not
like that bingo yeah much of the pastor
get into yes that's where we're getting
to and i always try to tell the
the up-and-coming guys you know always
something what type of product you
selling you know
like i'm we're both selling shirts
you're selling a shirt and i'm selling a
shirt what's going to make them want my
shirt a little bit more than your shirt
yeah you know you can be all for selling
shirts so if i want a shirt and just get
a shirt but no i want something special
yeah and i don't even care yeah yeah
maybe my quality is a little better than
your quality i took mine to a higher
level printer and it comes out just a
little more crisp and people can tell
and it shows so at the end of the day
like that's it max i took him i'm like
listen you gotta get more exciting kid
that even though you won it's kind of
[ __ ] boring just like i said you know
it's like give me a little something
let's just make it exciting you know
like going into that fight where like
you're you're where we at mentally we're
like right obviously he wants to take me
down
like your advantage is on the feet even
though he's got on the feet your your
knockout power your explosiveness your
athleticism is where you excel
especially against him so it was going
in just like all right i gotta catch us
dude in the first 30 seconds what are we
talking where's the the camps mentality
was what um
the councilman telly he's gonna wrestle
so we're trying to get our wrestling
timing together but again like i said
there's so many other things that did
not know what was happening in life for
instance the media stuff
media will [ __ ] your training up you're
gonna train you hey
stop can you say that again no no oh can
we turn music down oh no can you do one
of those things and can you do this and
stop and they're just getting them like
it was just so new you know like and not
even get worn i was driving to the gym
and all these cameras just came out i
was like what the [ __ ] like i'm on tmz
right now you know and they're kind of
getting them like like why they feel me
get on my car like there's not nothing
important you know yeah feel my training
cool you know and so just getting used
to all those different things that come
with it you know yeah it's a lot um
going back if if you would have told
yourself when you're 16 you'd be the
main event on a ufc card against
makachev when you were 17 resting at
fontana higher where the hell your high
school was would you have ever imagined
this
i would have wrestled harder
you were a good wrestler though
yeah um i wrestled
but i'm kind of like gachi
he's just stood in the back you know
it's cool
the wrestle but if you're not wrestling
and you're wrestling exciting like for
instance frankie edgar's wrestling was
exciting big happy
and that's exciting wrestling yeah it's
just not just the flashlight and the
brand yeah they're hugging you know and
at least bring some style points to that
you know
again what are you selling
so
i would tell myself uh wrestle harder
but would i believe that be here no i
was a broke kid brother you're like
my girl just showed me a picture of me
in the newspaper back then in high
school they did a little article on me
and it was the first time i'm in the
newspaper and it's the first time you
kind of connected like
what i'm doing how far you've made it i
had a story about my grandmother dying
and everything else and what i'm going
through and how i'm building this and
and i'm broken all these records like
for instance my high school i broke all
the numbers nobody still has broke my
record for being a two-time state placer
and blah blah blah
and so no i wouldn't imagine it and i'm
thankful for every woman i get yeah
yeah because you know you could have
went down a completely different path
and obviously it's a touchy subject but
obviously your younger brother went down
this path and then you decided thank god
you found wrestling you went down this
path you know so i think it's more so
than anyone you kind of know
the
the magnitude of that fork in the road
left or right been easy for you to go
left like your younger brother did bro i
would just be honest
i wish i could say that
it was me because i want to say there's
a bit of me
you know but your choices but i was
still a young kid myself my grandma died
when i was 14 years old 15 years old
my little brother
he's 12. and that's where he made the
decision to join a gang he's 12 years
old he doesn't know he just knows we're
hanging out with his buddies and we're
calling ourselves this you know yeah and
so
um 12. god that's young man yeah 12 when
he got into that street life but what
i'm saying is that it's just god okay my
soul i told you i got two brothers blood
and
both my blood i got a bunch of brothers
that are white mexican and everything
else with my two blood my bigger brother
got shot my other little brother got
killed yes you know homies all shot
killed blah blah blah
i'm just grateful to god that i just was
in the right place at the right time
somebody moved me here you know i'll be
honest i do i wouldn't try to say it was
me it was just god you know i could have
got shot san bernardino's [ __ ] raw
bro like yeah we got a raw rate murder
rate and everything else you know for
years like we can we can be competing
with l.a
and chicago and we've been competing for
years for that you know
yeah
and i you know i respect the whole god
thing but i think you have to give
yourself a little bit of credit you know
like i said a little you have to with
the discipline of wrestling and again
i've been easy the easy thing to do is
go to that street life but you've
decided to stay focused on wrestling and
yeah like when my brother and my brother
um went there i could have went too yes
but my grandmother
she texted me takes us in right my
grandma never like she was so tough on
me she was always mean
i always got all the different things i
had to clean the house i had the chores
i'd do all this different stuff you know
and
she never understood me finally the last
year of her life we finally just i got
it hey have coffee ready in the morning
when she wakes up
those floors already sweat and mop the
dishes better be cleaned you know and
once i did those things she just moved
easier through life but if she got up
and she saw dirty and i'm in there
watching tv watching cartoons she yeah
she's throwing [ __ ] over so we finally
made an understanding she's seeing
hey he's being this wrestler she'd come
home i come home she rubbed me and
alcohol hard work yeah all my sore
muscles it sounds like she respected
discipline and hard work she finally saw
me because i'm telling you she thought
it was gonna be a she knew how messed up
i was yeah
i was coming home with with bleached
hair bro i was that spiked hair like
like your type of hair we have the
[ __ ] we have the permanent [ __ ] and
then so i'd permit straight then i'd
bleach it blonde
i'd walk around with [ __ ] crazy ass
makeup on my face my grandmother was
wearing makeup oh [ __ ] yeah bro one time
i laid in a pool of kool-aid all red and
i dyed my hair red it was red spiked i
put red contacts in red clothes and i
sat in school and i was just sitting
there like this were you just looking
for attention or what are we doing yes
you're looking forward to changing mom
and dad you didn't really have a like uh
someone to follow right you didn't have
like a mentor and then i had a little
bit of uh what is the word uh
rebel rebellion i'm sure so i sit in
class
they remove me by third period because
you look crazy because i look crazy i'm
not saying anything i'm not doing
anything to anybody i'm just but also
you know
and they're like here comes security
yeah so you know what i did
i came back blue the next day oh wow
that's dedication though yeah bro and so
i'm dying my hair i'm doing all this
stuff
people are like well what are you gonna
do the next day i come back the next day
i come at superman it's nowhere near
uh the next day i'm coming back it's
santa claus there's nowhere near
christmas just every day you're coming
i'm doing a team wild stuff just to get
attention just to get attention you know
and so this is kind of built
my character of who i am who i am you
nervous nobody to look like bobby green
you see me go oh that's him that's why
you're in because why it's not the black
guys with tattoos on the head yeah it's
all about guys with a beard like that
yeah there's no other black guys that
look like him in the ufc look like him
yeah i'm just an individual i kind of
learned that from that
bro i would do some wild [ __ ] and like
it tripped me out that the school would
kick me out for what i was wearing it's
not against dress code like i work
sometimes i wear fishnets you know like
fishnets just fishing at see-through
fishnets and [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
sometimes i bleach my hair so much that
my hair would fall out yeah [ __ ] big
ass boss my bald spot that i have to
shave my head so i painted all white but
you know the skin would kick you out
just probably because you're a
distraction you know what i'm saying
that's what they said yeah that's
exactly what they said
now right as a kid i just didn't get it
no yeah i'm just like
i'm still trying to learn i just look
like a fish yeah yeah i'm still sitting
i'm not bothering i don't think cause
any problems no i would assume by
dressing up in those crazy styles the
gangs were like
we're gonna pass on bobby
right they're like the kids with the kid
with the no blue hair we don't need them
in the game no really they want more
you know right so you got to assume you
got it i got that from some white boys
okay these are the first guys that
actually looked up for instance oh i got
to say this you got what from white boys
like dying your hair and all that yes i
was a rock and roll guy i was in the
rock and roll marilyn manson you know
marilyn manson and all that crazy yeah
that's where i was looking like those
guys [ __ ] saying clown posse all that
[ __ ] [ __ ] nuts you know and so
jackass was around where are those
pictures jackass was around we're doing
[ __ ] wild kicking each other
i'm trying to wear some crazy [ __ ]
[ __ ] so
wait before you go on were you on the
wrestling team while you're dressing
like this i actually got kicked off the
team because my coach is like hey you're
still watching you can't yeah you can't
do that bro you're just too [ __ ] wild
yeah wrestling's like that's they're
opposite that they don't want the
attention yeah their work pin the guy
get out yeah who's this kid who keeps
coming because my idea of wrestling was
wwf
i thought wrestling was wwf yeah it's
not new i went in there and i was like
where's the turn
where's the tables and the chairs and
the yeah the turnbuckles and the you
know i'm gonna jump off the ropes and
get somebody in the people's elbows face
paint and [ __ ] yeah they're like what
are you nothing like so then we start
practicing i slam the guy and then go
actually you can't do that
what
you can't slam somebody wrestling no
actually you're supposed to put your
knee down before you slam them like wow
this [ __ ] is kind of gay and we gotta
wear these tight spin decks you know
so the opposite of what you were
thinking but i got free food so i stayed
so then you my coach would buy us free
food
on
on our dual meets in tournament day so
stuck around well you're uh going
through this phase we'll call it a face
while you're going through this
which i'm so excited about i can't wait
to see pictures but as you go it's a
picture here uh but while you're going
through the phase your younger and older
brother are they are they like
what like
where are they at on this okay so
my younger brother i mean my older
brother got taken away through through
foster care literally out of my arms
like so you have no idea one day i was
trying to run home i knew they were
gonna come get him and i finally got
home i got him and uh the social worker
was like he has to go he has to go and
they pulled him literally i'm orange
took him away i didn't see him for
another four years you know and you guys
are you guys were close yeah yeah i was
like my dad because we didn't have dads
he's like my dad so he went that way now
it's just me and my younger brother in
the home you know what i mean and so my
younger brother and my grandmother don't
know about this
i'm a black i'm black okay
and this is why i was inflating you my
grandma didn't understand my grandma we
didn't under getting didn't get me into
the last year of her life why because
she to black folks you don't do this
stupid [ __ ] yeah
i'm coming home normal so i go wake up
in the morning i go to my friend's house
my school's like five miles away i used
to walk to school for five miles to get
to school
but then i met these white boys i never
lost a fight before i get in the fight
with these white guys and they're doing
these weird things to me i never felt
before i've been in many fights and i
just knew that was something different
they were wrestlers ah they were doing
some legging in and putting in a pretzel
and bar halfing and i'm like what that
i have never been and these are white
guys i've never lost a fight especially
a white guy you know so i never forgot
it and i met the guys in high school
they got me into wrestling and now we're
doing the crazy white boy stuff yeah but
i can't tell my grandma you know because
grandma's gonna go crazy so grandma
don't know about this i've been doing
this [ __ ] for like
a good month grandma sees you dressed as
the crowd no no she don't i come out oh
she has my idea yeah i leave early in
the morning
i'll leave at five o'clock in the
morning to get to school by seven
so now that's how long it takes me to
walk to school yeah yeah you know i go
well the white guys white guys they get
to drive to school yeah so now we get to
take so now i'll meet up with them
earlier i'll leave my house and meet at
their house we come up with the [ __ ]
we're gonna do like oh you should do
this well you should wear a patch over
your eye well you should you should
shave your head and we're just like
we're [ __ ] down we're gonna do
whatever you know so we do it now i
don't know real quick though before you
go on about grandma would would the rest
of the white guys dress up too or are
they just dressing you up they dress up
too gotcha we're the pack of three and
we just [ __ ] well but i'm definitely
the most craziest of the three sure i'm
gonna push the [ __ ] envelope yeah you
know they'll kind of like wear a little
makeup and they'll do a little something
you know mascara but not me i'm [ __ ]
pushing it you know but um
so i go to school and as i come home
after practice with the wrestlers i go
back and i tink it all off yeah i get
back normal and i go home to grandma
yeah so grandma don't know yeah all of a
sudden now i'm becoming a distraction
it's becoming an everyday thing
now they're starting to report it to
grandma came home one day
i remember this [ __ ] vividly like did
they call your grandmother hey
bobby's dressed like krusty the clown we
gotta yeah so this is a hilarious ass
story i [ __ ] i hate using public
bathrooms okay yeah so i've been holding
my [ __ ] literally from third period yeah
holding it all day i don't want to use
the public bathrooms so i'm holding it
holding it are you dressed at the like
the crow at this time too
there's so many outfits i have no idea
sure so [ __ ]
i've been holding my [ __ ] all day i'm
[ __ ] getting home i'm walking and i
finally walk and i get over to this
little field we get over this field it's
a wall that goes into my neighborhood i
jump over the wall and as soon as i land
bam i [ __ ] just crashed myself
[ __ ] my pants are all like oh
so i'm [ __ ] doing the dude walk you
know walking home the last about a block
more sure i'm [ __ ] doing the doodle
walk i'm getting home i can open the
door my grandma's already there with the
belt we're waiting them because they
called and just
she just started whooping this [ __ ]
while you're filled with [ __ ] while i'm
filled with [ __ ] what a nightmare you
know then she washed my underwear too
that's how sweet she was she gave me you
should wash all my clothes out for
grandma
so so then your brother gets taken to
foster care your grandma doesn't know
you're dressing up like all these crazy
things you [ __ ] your pants and then your
little brother at this time right now
what's he is he just like
bobby's like where's little brother
little brother is already
influenced by the gang activity or with
no brothers with grandma so he's not
little brother didn't find the gangs
until grandma died gotcha grandma
that number mama and daddy grandma
wouldn't even let us do anything no type
of [ __ ] like once grandma left that's
when your your brother kind of went down
there grandma
the last year of our life
started seeing you're actually
successful wrestling yeah you're
actually doing pretty good and she
starts getting behind me yep and she's
like oh he's this kid's good
so
my last day my grandma was alive
she was sitting on the floor she's out
of breath
we had these little swamp fans that blow
and she said bye me bob she called me
came in there she was like
she held my hand and she was like do you
love me i left her dead and i told her
yes grandma i love you you know i went
to school
and then i got the call and so the last
day she died and i just put it in my in
my
memory bank
i'm gonna make i'm gonna make it for her
yep i'm gonna i'm gonna make her proud
you know because that was my mom and dad
and like you're supposed to make your
mom and dad proud so when she passes
what happens to you and your brother
that's where you don't have a guardian
right i now have to
figure out what i'm going to do
i've been working so hard at this
wrestling stuff
i feel i want to make her proud
to end it well you know
but my family's in rialto and one of my
aunts is gonna take taking my my little
brother
so i decide to not
go there and stay with this white family
to stay in montana to continue wrestling
correct
so i made a decision to go this way my
brother didn't have a choice he went
that way the the family had already
known me
for years being on the wrestling team
yeah and they knew i was a good kid they
knew that hey he's not he's a little
troubled but they saw me and they've
seen me for years enough to watch me go
we can take this little black boy you
know god bless him man yeah cool yeah
and to this day
we're tight oh really that's great
through this day i lost none of my
homies none of my friends unless they
cut their cells off you know that's
great man
and then going back to fighting you know
so
in the ufc
you know you've had this phenomenal
career you've got five of the nights and
you fought everybody and you're at the
end of your contract now
right and you did the ufc a solid fight
makachev
so i guess with the ufc i assume it's
good terms because you're actually a fan
favorite you're exciting fighter you
fought everybody so now it's
you know what would be best case
scenario for you i assume stay with ufc
stay with the ufc um
i'm a big person in loyalty i believe in
staying loyal to to which you is uh to
who the people that give you an
opportunity you know yeah like everybody
like for instance if me and you came up
together i would always come back to you
before i would go to anyone else just
because i met you first and and you
introduced me to this you know the ufc
has been good to you yeah they've been
good to me you know um like i said we've
told before that they paid for my
brother's funeral who was not killed i
didn't know that yeah they paid my
brother's funeral ufc paid for the
entire funeral yeah yeah this is my
and how long ago do you pass away
sheesh
2013 i want to say it is you know yeah
13. and so this is when i was first
getting into the ufc i've had my first
fight with them
and uh
money started getting low
i hadn't fought and i had a knee injury
my blew my knee out so i wasn't able to
fight
they said hey like
i was trying to do [ __ ] uh uh
car washes and and hustle we want to say
we tried to sell food plates and stuff
to raise money yeah let's get the money
up for it and then all of a sudden
um jason called and said the ufc said
they'll pay for it that's that's amazing
bro yeah and so that's always had me be
a soldier for them you know it makes
sense i'm down you know there's some
things that i didn't think that no
company would do or anyone would do for
me like that you know that's cool and
that's what that means to me like for my
little brother who's my heart it's just
like [ __ ] it takes me a long way you
know i'm a little bit different in terms
of when it comes to business yeah
business is cool and i understand like
business and and friendship and those
things are personal or different
but
sometimes
they can kind of intertwine like well
you did me a solid
i'm gonna do you a solid business yep
let's take a little break again from
chatting with bobby green and chowing
down on some delicious food because
we'll get right back to the show but
first i gotta tell you this man i'm on
the road a lot i do meet and greets and
a lot of y'all bros out there losing
your hair man a lot of you got the
george costanza going on you get that
jada pika smith going on two out of
three bros will experience some form of
hair loss by the time they're 35. more
than 50 million bros in the u.s suffer
from male pattern baldness it ain't good
thank god for my friends at keeps they
offer a simple affordable stress-free
way to keep your hair all you do meet
with a doctor virtually all right you
don't have to leave your home 24 7 care
and support it's low cost treatments are
just ten dollars a frickin month all
right it keeps has everything you need
to keep your hair it's delivered
straight to your door remember
prevention is key don't look like brian
callum before it's too late you're going
bald there's nothing you do treatments
take four to six months see results so
act fast if you're ready to take action
prevent hair loss go to keeps.com shobb
that's k-e-e-p-s dot com slash
s-e-h-a-u-b to receive your first month
of treatment for free that's keeps.com
to get your first month free
dot com shop now let's get back to the
show you know what's interesting too is
you you talk about your brother passing
not only did your brother pass thank god
the ufc paid for the funeral but then
you also have to fight josh thompson
oh brother
brother passes then you have to fight
josh thompson who's a you know close
friend of mine josh is a savage dude
okay um
[ __ ] brother like
you just took me back i just totally
forgot about that day you know on top of
that all to top it off um
i'm just in the ufc
there's some guy come to interview me i
don't know what i'm doing sure i don't
know anything about
interviews or anything like that i'm
just a kid yeah and the one thing about
me like my fans know bobby green's gonna
give you the real the raw the truth
that's how i feel this is how i feel i'm
just gonna tell you how it is now you
were signed to fight josh and then your
brother died during the chaos no no no i
got thrown in on short notice oh my god
i took the fight on two
weeks notice
you know what i'm saying jesus so i get
thrown in this fight i'm not even on the
poster they can't even change the
poacher to put my face on it they still
got michael johnson on it yep you know
and so uh
i'm dealing with that right
a reporter comes to interview me and try
to explain to him i'm not like any of
the other fighters okay i know you're
trying to get your way or you're trying
to do your thing his name is uh mark
ramundi yeah yeah okay you know you're
familiar with them right so mark's a
young guy you know i've seen all these
guys 30 years and i can see who they
were and how they're changing but anyway
mark comes young kid i'm like okay i'm a
young kid too we're talking about blah
and i'm telling him about my life and
i'm telling you everything i mean
everything
i'm just walking me through it and just
[ __ ] just laying it out you know and
just kind of give him an idea like
listen he's like telling me this the
first piece someone's going to do with
me i don't know what a piece is but i
felt like it was going to be more so
what i'm getting now is like a uh
embedded or a destiny or you know any
shows where you get more time to explain
i don't know so i'm just telling him it
turns out i told him some things that
happened to me that i felt was private
where a teacher
was touching on me yeah
and how great is that
i was about
17 you know 18 i was just turning 18
getting ready turning 18. um
and
it was a very private moment for me for
one two like i said i'm open but i'm
even saying out here because i have
nothing to hide you you thought uh
divulging that to that reporter you
didn't think he was going to write it i
didn't think he was going to write it
yeah and so i was explaining to him
all the different stuff of how my life
has been and how i got here and thinking
he's just going to write the piece and
know what not and not to he said no you
didn't say off the record oh wow and so
you have to say off the record for them
not to and i don't know
i don't know
solid so he put the article out
now the art comes out right
maybe a day or two before the fight
all of a sudden everybody remembers
seeing me because i was that standout
kid and knowed you crazy with the yeah
everybody remembers you and then i kind
of mellowed out and started to
understand
and also start hanging out with this
teacher so everybody remembers us both
they're pinpointing it hitting me up my
phone's going crazy oh we actually want
to put a case actually now it's getting
controversial now because he was still
working at the school you know and this
still was still transpiring and so now
i'm my brother's dead i'm fighting this
short notice fight my biggest fight of
the career i got this other stuff the
teachers were telling me that actually
you need to leave now that they want to
have to do some type of investigation
and blah blah blah yeah i'm just in my
bad [ __ ] ball and they're just crying
with so much pressure and so much
everything i'm feeling at that moment
you know i'm just trying to grieve with
my brother and it's just like
i don't know where i'm pulling the
string from but i'm going to do it you
know yeah and i actually won a fight so
that's right
i can't believe you won that fight yeah
that's insane
because josh is no punk that's insane uh
you i've wanted you on here for a while
man your story's so nutsos man and you
just keep doing the damn thing
as far as your division goes it's
stacked man after being there with mike
chev you think he's the the real deal is
he the next
world champion at 55
interesting
question you've been there all doesn't
pour it even there's some monsters man
um
when i was in there i was learning about
him
i finally felt like i got my got my
groove right okay i got you i got his
his timing and everything on the feet
but i still haven't got his wrestling
timing yet and how he's shooting and
what is he attacking and where we're
gonna go it's pretty good and and
so i do think he's championship material
i do think uh the utmost respect to him
he's strong as [ __ ] you know if i fought
him i would definitely need to be on on
weight training i don't lift weights or
anything like that you know um i need to
be on a more of a weight training
regiment
be strong enough to deal with uh that
pressure and just have my wrestling
timing ready for him you know yeah and
he's very smart oh yeah i i heard him
and khabib you know khabib keeps kept
saying
patience you always keep telling them
this patient be patient be in this
moment you think like go for the finish
yeah kabit tells you know be patient
don't move fast yeah you know i
recognize he just did these slow
methodical little moves that i didn't
even recognize very khabib style yeah it
could be very could be yes and i didn't
recognize that oh he already got here
yeah for instance like there was a
certain time in transition where he now
signed me down first of all on takedown
i made the stupidest mistake thinking
i'm gonna try to go for a little front
choke on them you know yeah suck my legs
out i don't know what the [ __ ] i was
thinking i should i've already fought
the first takedown off and i already had
success there i should have stuck to
that but i didn't realize how desperate
he was
he realized yes yeah yeah once we had an
exchange that kind of hit him in there a
little bit
he just started coming out let's take no
chances get you down yeah so once i
fought to take down off
he kind of
slowed down patience yeah they're just
patient and i thought oh it wasn't so
bad i'm like okay cool like i fought to
take down off like now give him a couple
of knees like this is not so bad you
know
then he had another attack i fought that
off and then we had a separation where i
thought he's giving up
like oh he's not gonna try to blow some
too much right now we got five rounds
yeah no he was i'm going i'm going
forward you know so he kind of gave us a
little gap and shot and dropped down
real low you know oh are you
[ __ ] yeah you said that's like
the real deal i'm curious you know
because obviously you've got uh
you got uh gaity you got charles
oliveira fighting it is the real deal
brother but it's just like
it's just wrestling yeah [ __ ] boring
like i don't like watching them yeah and
they just said it before when you even
you know it gets finishes like be honest
i felt the way about khabib that's what
i was going to say where you feel the
same way about the beep up until
he started at least fighting the gay
cheese the dustin's where at least
worked but to be honest
it was because he was fighting those
names yeah that had me watching more so
than i want to watch a khabib or a
makata fight yeah as far as
entertainment entertainment
entertainment for me why i fell in love
with khabib and moksha ii is how to
destroy they're so dominant and nobody
can figure it out yes and so to me it's
like turning into like man let's see if
we can see if he can see if they figure
yeah let's see if he yeah they just mop
like terminator style so it's just
watching to see if anybody can figure it
out nobody has that's what's fascinating
to me though let's try this way
say you're playing you play video games
okay so you ever had a friend we play a
video game right and he doesn't really
know how to play or he's not as good but
he just keeps doing a stupid little low
kick he's doing the same move over and
over over and over he's winning he's
winning yeah he's winning it's not fun
it's not fun yeah you're just like bro
this is stupid yeah
like
it's kind of boring like for me i
already tossed the tool out like all
right i started out as a wrestler toss
that tool out and show them because most
people think i'm a striker yeah like no
be honest i started as a wrestler then i
started doing jujitsu dragon king live
justin gates style yeah you know but
it's just a show
all right i already played with that and
that's cool and i could do some of that
stuff too
but i'm kind of like the guy where i'm
an artist yeah i look at it as art it's
not
like kabir look at it like it's a match
a [ __ ] i beat you a smasher
they're matches we win we win
no to me it's an art it's a painting i
call my style poetry in motion
meaning i want you to come in and watch
it and feel something deep about this
[ __ ] like man it's just art are you
sitting back and you just like
what the [ __ ] like this guy's doing you
know what he's just like talking to him
and he's doing it and he's and what like
you got a winner in uh charles oliveira
and justin gaichi
do i have a winner yeah who do you think
wins that
sheesh sheesh good fight right man like
you said these 55s are just so tough and
there's so many capabilities because
we're all pretty good at everything so
if it goes this way
you know i can see like if you have two
guys that you know they're just going to
stand like heavy oh well he's probably
going to get slapped these guys it could
go it could go there's so many options
um
i would think that the way that uh odds
have it gait is a slight underdog
underdog
i would say that i feel gaichi is gonna
catch him
i can see that happening you know what i
mean because i feel like charles comes
out
comes out get hit too and if you get hit
by gaity it's tough yes yeah i tell
everybody this there's certain people
that you fight that will change your
life you know i found a couple people
that they fought me and they retired
yeah they just realized like it's not
worth it yeah somebody said too hard
yeah hit too hard for instance when
geichi fought tony
took a couple years off his life
tony's so tough
tony and i'm gonna quit her that
he hit him a few times where i'm like oh
god that just that was so nasty that one
time the final hit he hit him pow and
tony tried and also he just he started
backing away like that now you just
couldn't take any more now you got tony
michael chandler coming up
great fight tony's [ __ ] tough as [ __ ]
he's really coming first he mocked up
too tough for his own good that he don't
even know
but i think something so bimilly
clicked where he just couldn't take
well dude i hope you sign a freaking 25
contract bfc i hope you get the biggest
names in the world there's a couple of
dads eating some chicken sandwiches
right now before you go man
oh you're not dab that bob man before
you go everyone that comes on i give
them a shoe that i think represents them
these from my boys at suplex in philly
they're super i thought you would give
me some crazy rainbow
i may be wearing some colors bro
maybe wear some color yeah i take some
fashion risks man i mean not like you in
high school
these are for you my man i know red your
thing
some red cakes we got some new ones now
hey
yes sir
those are your size my man
they go with the fit too yeah yeah i'm
like should i take these ones off yeah
yeah i hope you wear those your next
fight man oh [ __ ] yeah bro yeah i'm
locking them up get people on paper safe
yes
[Music]
super thick boy